so you want to make a difference yeah
trust me you're gonna love it and which
bronze are you interested in joining got
their pilot best of the gout
your name
holy crap everybody we got our first
look at the Han Solo movie in there
dropping an even bigger trailer tomorrow
but we saw all the big stuff all the
actors we finally got our first look at
Donald Glover as Lando Calrissian in
full-on pimp gear does he not look like
the most fly space pimp Billy Dee
Williams is probably gonna be so excited
about this although he probably wants to
be in some of these movies too we sell
logic at a whole bunch of Star Wars
movies they're gonna be making so maybe
they'll work him in somehow but this
basically tells you the story of the
Millennium Falcon like you see it all
shiny and new so we're probably gonna
see him win it from Lando but the dice
in the Millennium Falcon they're this
big
running Easter egg that they featured
prominently during last Jedi are
actually the dice that he used to win
the Millennium Falcon so it's sort of
like his lucky dice that he hangs up
they've always been there since a new
hope but people have always wondered
what they're all about so they're really
important to his character which is why
Luke Skywalker grabbed them during last
Jedi to give to Leia but I do love the
way that they opened the teaser to with
like the dead silence of him just
clicking all the switches on like he's
powering the Millennium Falcon on for
the first time although you also see him
at the Imperial Academy signing up what
do you want to be which division do you
want to go into I'm gonna be a pilot
best there ever was I love the way that
they've brained that Star Destroyer
moving through the eye of the Maelstrom
in Space two but as suspected they are
probably going to do a version of the
Kessel run so there were some toys that
came out recently people like okay you
know toys come out for all the movies
sometimes they give you clues about
what's going on and it was named the
Kessel run Millennium Falcon so that's
the main reason why people think that
they're actually doing that in this
movie so a lot of the seminal Han Solo
moments like him meeting Chewbacca for
the first time this movie will cover
that so it'll be interesting to see if
they ever do a sequel what that sequel
will cover
he's from Corellia that's probably where
he is here Woody Harrelson's character
might wind up being some room from the
cannon he used a roguish figure that's
sort of a mentor to Han Solo so it
doesn't look like he's a superior
officer or anything like that so he
might just be another smuggler that Han
Solo runs into while he's doing his
Imperial duties but if you don't know
the story of how he met Chewbacca for
the first time it's a legend story and
that's not canon anymore but
I have a feeling that that moment is
such a seminal moment in the characters
history that they'll bring it forward
like they have pulled stuff from legends
before like thrown and made it part of
the new Canon so I think that his
meeting with Chewbacca will be
relatively close to what it originally
was in the books but because the Empire
was using a lot of wookie slave labor to
construct the first Death Star like you
can see Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader
standing here looking as it's starting
to be constructed
Chewbacca got swept up in that there was
a bit of a revolt they were ordered to
kill all the Wookiees but Han Solo being
a good character at heart when a wall
saved them all and that's when they fell
in together but I'd be curious to see
how he winds up meeting Lando for the
first time during the movie because even
though he's a badass cape wearing space
pimp during Empire it sounds like he has
a lot of that going on right here too so
there might be some funny fake it till
you make it moments where like he still
has a lot of the personality that you
know from the Billy Dee Williams version
of the character but just not the means
that he has once we get to Empire you
got a lot of guts coming here after what
you pulled
[Music]
[Laughter]
he seems Emilia Clarke's character looks
like she's maybe part of the nobility
she might wind up being a Karelian too
but her name is Kiera that's why people
have been calling her Kiera as NK IRA
but it's actually spelled Qi apostrophe
RA we don't know who this droid is but
there were rumors that Thandie Newton
was going to be playing a non human
character so she might be one of the
droids during this film like we got k2s
oh this film might introduce another new
droid character the possibility of
successfully navigating an asteroid
field is approximately 3,720 to 1 ever
tell me the odds would you like to know
the probability of her using it against
you
it's high that's good quiet it's very
some new creatures what looks like a new
version of the cantina scene obviously a
lot of this is way shinier and way
better-looking than the stuff that we've
seen in Star Wars so far like this is
clear dichotomy where Han Solo comes
from like he's wearing this patchwork
clothing as he signs up for the Empire
but most of these sets that you see are
actually really polished and new looking
especially the Millennium Falcon
this is him fighting another alien on
top of that train this was like it's
probably gonna be one of the big action
set pieces of the film he kind of looks
like some sort of cybernetic alien
creature kind of looks like a bounty
hunter that may be working for the
Empire but he has a vibro plate that's
not a lightsaber but you can kind of see
the imagery that they're going for
there's a lot of people that have energy
weapons like that
[Music]
[Applause]
I wouldn't be surprised if this shot of
the Millennium Falcon corresponds with
that Star Destroyer coming for them
through that big Maelstrom like that
might be their way of teasing the Kessel
run in a really subtle way but remember
this is only like 45 seconds of footage
the trailer that they drop tomorrow will
have a lot more so we'll get a little
more context for that but just everybody
let me know what your reactions are
based on this so far and do you think
that Boba Fett is gonna pop up during
the film because he's been rumored for a
long time they were gonna do that Boba
Fett movie the josh trank was gonna make
but then all that blowout with Fantastic
Four happened a couple years ago and
then it just mysteriously disappeared
from Lucas Films schedule like what Boba
Fett movie there was never a Boba Fett
movie we don't know what you're talking
about even though we saw a logo but
either way there's a whole bunch more
Super Bowl trailers dropping today so be
sure to subscribe to get everything make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos infinity war will be dropping
later tonight they've been ramping up so
we'll probably get that during halftime
but you can click here for brand-new
infinity war footage and you can click
here for all my episode 9 predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight